[Musique]
alors que les sirènes retentissent
l'inquiétude
ces ukrainiens se dirige vers la gare
vie vient d'être frappé par au moins
quatre missiles russes
les colonnes de fumée sont visibles à
des kilomètres
selon les autorités ukrainiennes des
infrastructures militaires et ce garage
automobile civils ont été visés près de
cette voie ferrée
ce responsable militaire dresse un
premier bilan
sept personnes ont été tuées et onze
autres ont été blessés selon les
premières informations
les décombres sont en train d'être
fouillé il pourrait y avoir plus de
victimes
ils vivent est située à l'ouest du pays
près de la frontière polonaise rares
sont les frappes aussi proche du centre
de la ville à une quarantaine de
kilomètres de là le 13 mars c'est une
base militaire qui avait été visé par
moscou faisant au moins 35 morts et 134
blessés
après les frappes de ce matin le
conseiller du président ukrainien a
tweeté les ruches continue d'attaquer de
manière barbare les villes ukrainiennes
depuis les airs déclarant cyniquement au
monde entier leur droit de tuer des
ukrainiens ni le président volodymyr et
l'ins qui nie la communauté
internationale n'ont pour l'heure réagi
aux nouvelles attaques russes